How do you speak truth to power when you work in an environment where
speaking truth to power can get you fired or
could get you in trouble?
One of the reasons that happens
is not because we're necessarily
"speaking truth to power"
it's the manner in which we do it.
We usually do it as a complaint
or we do it as an aggressive question
and we also do it without empathy.
One of the most important things to do is
have empathy for the people who we work for.
We don't know what their story is,
we don't know what kind of pressure they're under,
we don't know if they're operating from a point
of fear.
And so when we come in guns blazing
their walls are gonna go up
because we're aggressive or we're
perceived as aggressive.
So if you can maintain empathy
and some curiosity
and work hard to spend the time to
build a relationship
with that person in that authority position
so they understand that we want to
see them succeed.
And I want to ask you some
questions
because if you can answer these questions
I can be more successful,
which is gonna help you be more successful.
Or to say things like,
"Are you OK?"
"Hey, you were really harsh to us in the meeting today,
I just want to check in with you.
Is everything okay?"
These are little things
we can do to think about them as human beings
rather than oppressors
and to operate with as much empathy and curiosity
as possible
and hopefully build that relationship
so they see us as trusted and trusting
and amazingly they'll probably open up
and you'll learn a lot more so, that works.